- But do people still recognize
you from the voiceover?
I mean, I feel like
you're Dwight everywhere.
Like, I feel like you can't go anywhere
and people still recognize you.
- I will be Dwight to my, to my grave.
- I will be the girl that
sings "Since You've Been Gone."
So we're, here we go.
- You sang that?
I love that song.
- That's that's what I
will be, so it's like.
- Well, you were also, "Kelly Clarkson"!
- Yes, that too.
- You were also that.
- Thank you, Steve Carell.
Yes, yes, there's that as well.
- Yeah, what was the question?
- That's all I've done in my whole career.
That's what I would say.
No, are you, 'cause do you,
I heard that you tweeted this.
So let me show everybody what you tweeted.
So you were at dentist's
office, put on a mask
because the woman next to me
has a Dunder Mifflin shirt on.
(audience laughs)
Which you have to be a
hardcore fan, I'm just saying.
- Yeah.
- To be wearing that shirt.
So one, did your root canal go well?
'Cause you were at the dentist.
And I heard it was a root canal, but two
do you get nervous in that situation?
'Cause you're trapped.
You're like trapped there,
so you can't be like
nice and then head off.
- Yeah, I was going in without a mask
and I saw her and her kid
and she had a Dunder Mifflin
t-shirt and so I was like,
Ooh, this is so awkward.
I'm gonna have to sit for
15 minutes with this woman.
So I went and got a mask so,
- Or maybe longer in the waiting room.
- Maybe longer, so I went in incognito,
so we just didn't have to
have the awkward conversation
but I appreciate the fans so much.
- But it's not about
the awkward conversa-,
It's like, it's a fine conversation,
then it's awkward when it's just quiet
and you've talked about it
and you're just sitting
so closely together.
- Right, and you're just sitting there.
- That's the awkward
part, when you're like,
yeah, we're just both here.